what's up it's chris welcome back to
another episode and today we're gonna
find a date for sushi sushi you're gonna
try three different indian dishes cooked
by three different single girls and then
you get to decide who you are gonna go
on a date with just based on those
dishes sound good fantastic awesome my
american friends call me sushi i'm 26 i
grew up in mumbai india and i've been in
new york for about eight years now i
love dating and food and dating
i can't wait i would like to meet
someone that's really goofy and
ambitious and just trying to get the
most out of life hi i'm angela hey it's
ferrari hi i'm [ __ ] how are you feeling
about today nervous a little nervous
yeah just found out our guy is
vegetarian so
now i don't know how i'm feeling kind of
threw you under the bus right there
yeah you know but it's okay
i made alu gobi so it's potato
cauliflower tomatoes and onion and a lot
of different spices like garam masala
haldi and a lot of red peppers it has
all the hearty vegetables in it but it's
very spicy so it's a kick i think it
describes me it's simple but it's also
very extravagant and fire away oh wow
delicious let's take a moment to observe
this eat with your eyes what i like
about this dish is that it's honest this
is me this is me it's not trying to hide
anything going on i think that is really
really cool and important to me i do
worry though it doesn't look like enough
i have more i hope there's enough spice
going on in here oh he likes spicy food
nausea of approval i like it i got to
mix it up a bit but it's not overbearing
and i like that i like when people are
not overbearing i like the balance
behind it i feel like someone definitely
put a lot of attention to detail and
care that's super important to me are
there any red flags any red flags red
flags now that i have this kind of
burning sensation in my throat now that
i've given it a minute i'm a bit worried
i'm a bit worried that i might have
misjudged this seemingly i'm hoping
you're as spicy as she is
i'm a spicy guy okay let's let's not
beat around the bush i do kind of like
firecracker type of people that are like
you know oh super sweet nice whatever
and then bam whoa they're like they're
wild they go out crazy yes i like i like
that that's literally exactly how i
describe myself i do get the sense that
this person is confident here's the dish
you know what it is we don't need to
like mix about and like hide anything
why is he reading you like a book right
now
how much do you want to go on a date
with them
i would i would be inclined to go on a
date with this person um i i'm not
is something else going to come around
in 10 minutes i don't know so i don't
i'm not fully there but i'm mostly there
keep these options open
[Music]
i made some thundery chicken you just
marinate it in some yogurt lemon juice
some spice seasoning then you bake it in
the oven and you add some coloring as
well and i just presented it with some
garnishing on top so it's very colorful
it looks very fun i feel like that's me
i hope he likes the look of it since he
can't eat it he'll appreciate how
recognizably tendery it is right yes
that is a that is a hefty meal funny
story over about the last year i became
vegetarian so i haven't had chicken in a
very very long time this is a gorgeous
meal if you are what you eat then the
person that made this is a 10 out of 10.
i feel like they're very good at
aesthetic things so i feel like they
they probably have an apartment
somewhere in a quiet part of brooklyn
really minimalist i wish grugs
everywhere just you showed up with a
louis bag they showed up with a louie
bag i sure did so they they have that
apartment just on the upper west side oh
no one day shushant i forgot to check
that you were vegetarian i forgot to
tell them so don't hold it against them
she didn't know but also she didn't
really ask
chris not you lying on me i know you did
not just lie so this person didn't ask
if i was vegetarian which is um terrible
to assume as a former non-vegetarian i
would never assume however for this
person's sake i'll take the tiniest bite
he's nice for that yeah you're bold
moment of truth he's about to be like
all right i'm going back to me it's so
chewy he took the smallest bite he's
been she said it's just 20 minutes it's
like i don't miss it at all it looks
pretty but it seems so satisfied i don't
get the sense of adventure from this i
do like the safety and comfort that i
feel here i get the sense this person's
a homebody boy is he wrong no i'm
kidding
i'd be out every week
so i made samosas i mash a couple
potatoes fried them with a bunch of
spices and then i stuffed them into the
dough that i made and then i fried it
all together and then added a bunch of
spices with the potatoes so i think it
balances it out i like simple cooking
that's just how i am it's nice to be
mysterious a little bit keep it simple
it's a tease it's a tease yeah
this is awesome because it's not an easy
dish to make to be able to get that like
fold and everything impossible whoever
did this put a lot of effort and i
really appreciate that i can't wait to
dig in
oh he loves digging
watch the roast come in later though
that's good i have not had a good samosa
in a long time whoever did this really
likes to have a good time really likes
to enjoy life doesn't take it too
seriously i think that's me i really
like that i really like what's going on
i'm not so short about this thing i saw
that coming i don't know if this belongs
here but we're gonna give it a shot and
see he doesn't like spicy don't
nope um
it's it's so i i don't know what this is
you can't handle the heat you got to get
out the kitchen so she actually came in
without a sauce and then she saw how
nice the other dishes looked and was
like okay i need a sauce and she was
actually asking me if there was any
ketchup here and i couldn't find any so
she just grabbed that oh that's such a
bummer because like less is more that's
kind of my fault i told you to do that i
get the sense that you might have been
worried and i wish you weren't worried
because this was great i've been an
insecure person in my past relationships
i don't want to be that person i'm not
going to fault you for bringing the
sauce out i guess i'm insecure first
impression tells me that um you saw the
competition were a little worried and uh
not a good sign not a good sign but
great you're fun i'd love to i'd love to
hang out i feel like we would really
chill and get along wish you just didn't
worry i know right it's like sorry
all right sushi who are you going on a
date with
so when it comes to the chicken i love
the way your apartment looks i think
you're a great interior designer
aesthetics on point but we fundamentally
disconnect the samosas i love
what you bring but i wish you didn't
worry too much with the gobi aloo and
the rice slightly innocent and sweet and
then bam uh kind of hits you with it you
know is all in all a good time
absolutely win a winner not chicken
dinner i guess oh firecracker you're the
one let's fall in love
you want to meet them
hello
oh my god hi it's so nice to meet you
it's nice meeting you i'm [ __ ]
ferrari ferrari i'm angela angela nice
to meet you all thank you for preparing
so much delicious food i'm really
surprised you picked that over that one
i knew you couldn't pick this one
it was it was it wasn't like a personal
thing as i'm sure you know yeah you let
him have it because he had a lot to say
about you did i
oh you you've heard what i said yeah oh
that's not good
all right so now you guys are going to
go off on a little mini date you're
going to talk for a bit and then
afterwards we'll check in and see if you
guys want to go on another date after
that
[Music]
how are you guys are you going on
another date is this a thing you're
getting married
what's the deal i think it was a fun
date like i said firecracker we got we
got along very well just like you know
the banter was dope so i'm very happy
that we went on a date we are getting
married
yes
here we go oh my god we did it best date
ever you guys are all invited i know you
guys love it
same yeah you can be there but you can't
prepare the food
[Music]
you